>>> FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP TAKING CENTER STAGE AT A
CAMPAIGN RALLY IN NEVADA, USING
THE EVENT TO TALK JANUARY 6th.
NOT THE ATTACK, BUT THE CROWD
SIZE.
>> THEY NEVER WANT TO SHOW HOW
MASSIVE OUR CROWD WAS.
YOU KNOW THE BIGGEST CROWD I'VE
EVER SEEN?
JANUARY 6th.
AND YOU NEVER HEAR THAT.
IT WAS THE BIGGEST.
AND THEY WERE THERE LARGELY TO
PROTEST A CORRUPT AND RIGGED AND
STOLEN ELECTION.
THE BIGGEST CROWD AND YOU NEVER
HEAR THAT.
AND YOU SEE VERY FEW PICTURES OF
IT.
BUT THAT WAS THE BIGGEST CROWD I
BELIEVE I'VE EVER SPOKEN TO.
>> MY NEXT GUESTS ARE OUT WITH A
DETAILED ACCOUNT OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY AND MAKE THE ARGUMENT
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th WAS
THE CULMINATION OF A SUSTAINED,
FOUR-YEAR WAR ON THE
INSTITUTIONS AND TRADITIONS OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
THE BOOK IS BASED ON EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH BY SUSAN GLASSER AND
PETER BAKER, INCLUDING 300
INTERVIEWS, TWO OF WHICH
HAPPENED WITH DONALD TRUMP IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY BOTH JOIN ME NOW.
IT'S REALLY A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
BOTH OF YOU WITH US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CAN I JUST ASK YOU VERY QUICKLY
BEFORE WE JUMP INTO THE BOOK, TO
HEAR DONALD TRUMP OUT THERE ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, HERE WE ARE
A MONTH -- LESS THAN A MONTH
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS AND HE'S
TALKING ABOUT HIS CROWD SIZE ON
JANUARY 6th.
AND THAT CRASS SORT OF WAY.
I JUST WONDER WHAT YOUR REACTION
IS?
PETER, WE COVERED HIM SO CLOSELY
FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
WHEN YOU SEE HIM, DO YOU JUST
SAY THERE GOES TRUMP AGAIN,
THAT'S WHO WE COVERED, HE'S
NEVER GOING TO CHANGE, OR DO YOU
FIND SOMETHING DISTURBING AND
SOMEWHAT DANGEROUS ABOUT THIS
MOMENT RIGHT NOW THAT WE'RE IN?
>> YEAH, I THINK HE'S
CELEBRATING IN EFFECT THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
HE MAY NOT APPROVE OF THE ATTACK
ON THE CAPITOL, BUT CELEBRATING
THAT CROWD, THAT'S THE MESSAGE.
THE OTHER THING HE SAID LAST
NIGHT, HE ACCUSED DEMOCRATS OF
PUTTING IN JAIL THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THE ONLY POLITICAL OPPONENTS PUT
IN JAIL SINCE TRUMP LEFT OFFICE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ATTACKED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
SO THE THAT'S WHO HE MEANS,
AGAIN, HE'S HOLDING THEM OUT AS
HEROES OF HIS MOVEMENT AND
CAUSE, WHICH I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT.
IT RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DANGEROUS LEVEL OF THIS
RHETORIC.
IT'S CONGRATULATING PEOPLE FOR
TRYING TO TAKE IT INTO THEIR
HANDS, TAKING VIOLENCE AS A
MEANS TO TRY TO DISRUPT THE
TRANSFER OF POWER.
>> AND SUSAN, FROM A HISTORICAL
STANDPOINT, WE JUST LOOK AT THE
LAST CENTURY OR SO OF WORLD
HISTORY, THERE ARE PARALLELS.
IT SEEMS LIKE HISTORY IS TALKING
TO US.
WHEN YOU SEE A FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO INCITED AN INSURRECTION AND
GETTING THOSE KIND OF CHEERS.
>> WELL LOOK, THAT'S RIGHT.
CERTAINLY THERE'S A PRECEDENT
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES.
DONALD TRUMP HAS OPERATED WITH A
PLAYBOOK OF RUSSIA, WHERE THE
DEMOCRACY WAS UNDER ATTACK GOING
AFTER INDEPENDENT MEDIA, GOING
AFTER THE INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY
OR, YOU KNOW, OTHER POTENTIAL
RIVAL POWER CENTERS.
THAT'S RIGHT OUT OF NOT ONLY
TRUMP'S PLAYBOOK, BUT MANY
OTHERS.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT HISTORY,
JIM, I WOULD SAY THE THING
THAT'S SO REMARKABLE, AS YOU
CONTEMPLATE THE TRUMP
PHENOMENON, THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY,
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, EVEN IN
MANY PERIODS OF CONFLICT,
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A PRESIDENT
WHO SOUGHT TO OVERTURN THE
RESULTS OF AN ELECTION.
SO I FEEL LIKE TWO YEARS LATER,
THE FACT THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS REMAIN TETHERED TO
TRUMP PUTS IT IN UNCHARTED
TERRITORY, EVEN BY HISTORY'S
STANDARDS.
>> PETER, ONE THING YOU TALK
ABOUT IN THE BOOK IS HOW TRUMP'S
DAUGHTER AND SON-IN-LAW, IVANKA
TRUMP AND JARED KUSHNER, WASHED
THEIR HANDS OF ALL OF THIS
STOLEN ELECTION TALK BEFORE THE
RESULTS WERE CALLED, AND THAT
OPENED THE DOOR FOR SOME OF THE
CRAZIES TO COME IN.
THE CRAZIES APPEAR TO STILL BE
THERE, BUT TELL US ABOUT WHAT
YOU WROTE ABOUT IN THE BOOK.
>> WELL, THAT'S RIGHT.
BASICALLY TWO DAYS AFTER THE
ELECTION, BEFORE THE NETWORKS
HAD CALLED IT, JARED KUSHNER
WOKE UP IN HIS HOUSE HERE IN
WASHINGTON AND TOLD IVANKA HEY,
WE'RE MOVING TO MIAMI.
WITHIN A FEW WEEKS, THEY PICKED
OUT A $32 MILLION PROPERTY DOWN
IN FLORIDA, LOOKING AT SCHOOLS
FOR THEIR KIDS.
THEY KNEW THE ELECTION WAS OVER.
THEY KNEW IT HADN'T BEEN STOLEN.
THEY KNEW IT WAS NOT GOING TO BE
OVERTURNED.
BUT RATHER THAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE DEBATE THAT WAS GOING ON IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, KUSHNER SAID
I'M NOT GOING TO BE PART OF
THIS.
THAT GAVE PEOPLE LIKE RUDY
GIULIANI AND SIDNEY POWELL AND
JOHN EASTMAN AND MIKE LINDELL,
THERE WAS A VOID THEY FILLED
WHISPERING INTO THE PRESIDENT'S
EAR, YES, YOU CAN OVERTURN THIS,
YES, YOU LOST WITHOUT FEAR.
HIS OWN SON-IN-LAW WENT OFF TO
THE MIDDLE EAST TO WORK ON PEACE
AND MAYBE FUTURE BUSINESS
CONTACTS, AS WELL AS MOVING HIS
FAMILY TO MIAMI.
>> I REMEMBER SEEING MIKE
LINDELL HANGING OUTSIDE THE WEST
WING AND THINKING THIS GUY IS
NOT HERE TO SELL PILLOWS.
SUSAN, I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS ANECDOTE IN THE BOOK WHERE
YOU WRITE ABOUT THEN CHIEF OF
STAFF JOHN KELLY, WITH A QUITE
SURPRISING BOOK THAT HE HOPES
WILL HELP HIM UNDERSTAND HIS
BOSS.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT WAS ONE OF THE AMAZING
THINGS WHEN WE DID THIS
REPORTING IS TO SEE HOW THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT TRUMP IS SO
DISTURBING AND HAS COME FROM
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS, FROM HIS
OWN APPOINTEES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
JOHN KELLY, RETIRED FOUR-STAR
MARINE GENERAL, TOLD OTHERS THAT
HE PURCHASED A BOOK BY A COUPLE
DOZEN MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, "THE DANGEROUS
CASE OF DONALD TRUMP" TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
BASIS OF THIS VERY DISRUPTIVE
PRESIDENT HE WAS DEALING WITH.
HE TOLD OTHERS THAT IT WAS
HELPFUL.
WE HAVE REPORTING FOR THE BOOK
THAT SHOWED THAT THERE WERE EVEN
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CABINET WHO
WOULD ROUTINELY DEBATE IF DONALD
TRUMP, IN THE WORDS OF ONE
CABINET OFFICIAL WAS CRAZY
CRAZY, OR JUST ACTING CRAZY.
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY, AGAIN, A
WAY IN WHICH TRUMP WAS A REAL
OUTLIER AMONG AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS.
AND VERY, VERY CHALLENGING, AS
YOU SEE HIM NOW BECOMING EVER
MORE DRAMATIC IN THE EFFORT TO
APPEAL OR TO KEEP HIS HOLD OVER
HIS FOLLOWERS.
RALLIES LIKE LAST NIGHT, IN SOME
WAYS ARE MORE PROVOCATIVE THAN
THE RALLIES HE WAS HOLDING IN
2020, AS HE SEEKS TO MAINTAIN
HIS POLITICAL APPEAL.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHEN I WATCH HIM AT THESE
RALLIES, IS HE TRYING TO HANG ON
TO WHAT HE HAS OR TRYING TO
RECLAIM THE PRESIDENCY?
PERHAPS IT'S JUST AS SIMPLE,
PETER, AS HE DOESN'T WANT TO LET
THIS FOLLOWING GET AWAY FROM
HIM.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT HE MAY RUN IN
2024.
IF HE DOESN'T, HE WON'T TELL US
UNTIL THE LAST POSSIBLE MOMENT.
HE DOES CRAVE THE ATTENTION.
HE CRAVES THESE RALLIES AND THE
MONEY THAT COMES IN THROUGH
FUND-RAISING, AS LONG AS HE'S A
POSSIBLE CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT.
WITH ALL THESE INVESTIGATIONS
SWIRLING AROUND HIM, THERE'S
ANOTHER MOTIVE TO RUN, AS WELL.
HE POSSIBLY THINKS THAT BEING A
CANDIDATE MIGHT PROTECT HIM IN
SOME WAYS AND MIGHT BE MORE
RELCTANT TO CHARGE -- OR RALLY
THESE CROWDS THAT HE'S A MARTYR
OF THE DEEP STATE.
SO IN SOME WAYS THESE RALLIES
ARE JUST AS SIGNIFICANT TODAY AS
THEY WERE WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
>> SUSAN, NOT THAT WE NEED
ANOTHER JURASSIC PARK SEQUEL,
BUT TRUMP IS COMPARED TO THE
VELOCIRAPTORS IN THE PARK THAT
LEARN HOW TO OPEN THE DOORS WHEN
HUNTING THEIR PREYS.
I WILL CONFESS THAT IS ONE OF
THE MORE TERRIFYING MOMENTS IN
THAT MOVIE.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> YEAH, THAT WAS A CHILLING
MOMENT WHEN I WAS SPEAKING WITH
A FORMER VERY SENIOR NATIONAL
SECURITY OFFICIAL WHO SPENT A
GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WITH DONALD TRUMP AND
MADE THE OBSERVATION COMPARING
HIM TO THE VELOCIRAPTOR WHO
LEARNED TO OPEN THE DOOR.
WE REMEMBER THAT SCENE WITH THE
CHILDREN HIDING IN THE KITCHEN,
AND THEY'RE NOT SAFE.
THE POINT WAS ABOUT TRUMP, IN
HIS SECOND TERM, TRUMP HAD HE
BEEN RE-ELECTED, IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN A MORE DANGEROUS, EFFECTIVE
CHARACTER THAN HE WAS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PRESIDENCY.
PEOPLE OFTEN FORGET THAT TRUMP
WAS THE LEAST EXPERIENCED
PRESIDENT IN SOME WAYS IN MODERN
TIMES IN TERMS OF GOVERNING.
HE NEVER SERVED A SINGLE DAY IN
GOVERNMENT OR IN THE MILITARY,
UNLIKE EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
HE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHO HE WAS
SURROUNDING HIMSELF WITH AT
FIRST.
BUT OVER THE COURSE OF THE FOUR
YEARS, HE LEARNED TO OPERATE THE
MACHENRY OF GOVERNMENT TO GET
WHAT HE WANTED.
HE FIRED THOUSANDS OF CIVIL
SERVANTS, POTENTIALLY IN A
SECOND TRUMP TERM.
I THINK HE WOULD PURSUE MANY OF
THOSE AGENDA ITEMS THAT HE
DIDN'T MANAGE TO GET DONE IN A
FIRST TERM, THINGS LIKE NOT JUST
BUILDING THE WALL BUT
WITHDRAWING FROM NATO, JOHN
BOLTON AND OTHERS SAID THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN TOP OF HIS
SECOND TERM AGENDA.
HE TALKED TO US ABOUT HIS
WILLINGNESS TO HOLD UP SOUTH
KOREA FOR BILLIONS MORE OR ELSE
HE WOULD WITHDRAW U.S. TROOPS
FROM SOUTH KOREA.
THAT WAS FROM OUR INTERVIEW IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> HE SEEMS TO THINK THAT HE CAN
CONDUCT THIS KIND OF FOREIGN
POLICY, YOU KNOW, IF HE GETS
BACK INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT IS REMARKABLE TO THINK ABOUT.
I TALKED TO ADVISERS WHO SAID TO
ME IF HE GETS BACK IN THERE IT
WILL BE TRUMPISM ON STEROIDS.
ALL RIGHT, PETER AND SUSAN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BREAK TALKING TO BOTH OF YOU.
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUC